I have so many things to say about her
very excited to see a girl in the cow
are you talking about casting him no I'm
not I don't have my eye on anybody I
feel like I want I'm creating this
character I'm in a dialogue with her and
then we'll see who joins that later on
Oh name in mind that you thought it for
the part I doubt it'll be a name I think
this is somewhere where you go and find
that girl or any cast her when the
audience and don't look out and say we
know that person or idea fresh face and
just think of focusing on the character
I mean I'm not against movie stars
they're great but you need somebody
who's going to be just right and the
situation like this the name has a lot
of weight so it's not as critical you
know so definitely Vin Diesel
you have to appreciate that Vin Diesel
joke that'd be the most terrifying
version of Batgirl ever tumbler get on
that that'd just be horrific
so what I'm gonna do is I'll explain
more about what he said about the
Batgirl movie he teased that he was
actually talking to DC about a different
project when they came up with the idea
to do the Batgirl movie in the story
that's largely going to inform that
which I believe will take mostly from
the Batgirl of Burnside but they're not
going to do an exact comic book story
which I'll explain in DC also dropped a
new Superman promo for the Justice
League movie that's coming this November
so also explain how Batgirl fits into
the context of the DC EU in the Justice
League movie because they haven't even
cast her they're still writing the movie
but the Nightwing movie all these other
things that they're doing they all
connect with Justice League so it sounds
way more complicated than it actually is
but if you're new to the channel there
is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway going on all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video starting with Joss
Whedon's Batgirl
mostly what he's talking about is in not
casting a big name which I'm all for
like you don't want someone to
overshadow the role it's sort of the
opposite approach that Marvel's taking
with Captain Marvel casting brie Larson
who's an amazing actress but I just feel
like with all the stuff that's been
going on the drama the DC EU they're
better off casting an unknown because
most of the focus now is going on with
Justice League and Wonder Woman these
high-profile characters so they can kind
of sneak in Batgirl on the DL and make a
surprise sleeper hit so a lot of that
goes into what version of her character
she is because there's been a lot of
different back girl stories she's been
Oracle for a big period in the comics
the new 52 retcons some of those things
and turned her into more of a
college-aged Batgirl which i think is
basically where they're going because
they're doing a Nightwing movie and
it'll be a relatively middle-aged
version of the character think about
Batman being in his 40s so you have to
imagine that Knightley is 20 plus years
younger
Batgirl will have parity with him and
they even have a romantic history a very
long romantic history in the comics
maybe they'll choose to do that
on-screen usually stuff like that isn't
like they had a relationship at one
point but they're estranged now it just
becomes part of the drama of the
universe so maybe Nightwing can cameo
and Batgirl and Batgirl can cameo in the
Nightwing movie but because they
just announced the director of the
Nightwing movie right before they
announced Joss Whedon for Batgirl
there's still so much stuff that they
haven't decided yet they're still
writing the stories of both of those
movies in just a chart this in the
timeline if you're wondering like when
we're actually going to see this movie
talking about Batgirl the Captain Marvel
movie is a good benchmark for that
they're getting ready to shoot that
early next year if they've been working
on the script for that for the last year
or so and they just found the director
and Captain Marvel isn't shooting til
early next year that gives you an idea
of how far out it's going to be before
they start shooting the Batgirl movie so
even if Joss Whedon finishes his script
by the end of the year and they find
their actress early next year they
probably won't start shooting at the
earliest til the end of next year
meaning you'd be late 2019 early 2020
before we actually see the Batgirl movie
and it all just depends on how long it
takes them to finish the script and find
the actress so like he says in his
interview he's going to find his Batgirl
on the page first and then they'll find
the right actress for that so what I
expect is is that they'll have some more
news about Nightwing and Batgirl at
Comic Con but they'll still be working
on those very early stages I'd be very
surprised that they announce who the
actors are going to be for those movies
most of their comic-con will be spent
hyping up Justice League proper in the
Aquaman movie but a twenty-something
post Killing Joke Batgirl so if he
didn't read the new 52 version of
Batgirl you're like hey wait a minute
isn't she in a wheelchair how can she be
Batgirl
if the Joker took her ability to walk so
when they did the new 52 reboot way way
back in 2011 what they did with the
Batgirl character is they said that she
still went through that but because they
wanted to get her out of the wheelchair
what they did is they said that she went
through extensive rehab had a lot of
medical treatment and was slowly able to
overcome her disability she moved out of
her apartment into the Burnside area of
Gotham one of the more affordable places
that young people live in Gotham City
that isn't crime alley just riddled with
crack dealers everywhere but she's in
school she puts back on the cape and
cowl becomes the bat girl persona again
and it becomes sort of like a daredevil
type you know street-level version of
Batman that's localized to the Burnside
neighborhood
so whereas Batman appear
in like 70 billion comics and goes all
over the globe tackling villains Batgirl
in the new 52 in this Burnside storyline
Mosely stays localized to Burnside
fighting criminals localized to that
borough of the city so the arc of like
the first volume of that comic was all
about her reestablishing her identity
finding out who she was after she got
out of the wheelchair making a name for
herself establishing herself in the
community as a hero that likes to help
people and yes there are a couple
villains that she punches in the face
but the true villain of that story is
really herself something that she did
that comes back to haunt her so without
giving away too much the villain of that
story throws her past at her and makes
her confront it so she's able to move
past it so she grows as a person is a
really artful way to show how even
though she's experienced all this
tragedy she's been wounded physically
she spent a large portion of her life in
a wheelchair she was able to conquer
that and DC didn't like all wipe it away
and say that it never happened if you
watch Jessica Jones it's kind of like
that way more interesting way more
complicated version of the Batgirl
character so that's part of what
attracted Joss Whedon to the project and
you wonder like if he was talking to DC
about another project when they came up
with this what was that other project
during that Batgirl comic though there
was only very brief Batman family
Nightwing crossover so I'm hoping that
for the nightly movie they draw more
from rebirth era but there's always a
lot of stuff as they pulled from way
back and the original origins of the
character and does all this talk of
doing a Teen Titans movie so that's all
floating in the background that might
have been the other project that Joss
Whedon was talking about maybe doing
Teen Titans after they do the Nightwing
movie but we can talk about that when
they announce more stuff the superman
promo is the other big thing so what's
happening here is that they're trying to
market the film in a really weird way
with this website where they're
releasing new content if you remember
the Deadpool core that Fox did that was
sort of a website they used to release
content via email it's kind of what
they're doing with Justice League so to
announce this they posted this Superman
promo with the Justice League and it's
like hey wait a minute this isn't like
the version that you posted a little
while ago before the trailer came out
why is Superman front and center well
what they did is is the website
they built had like a secret toad built
into it it would reveal Superman
eventually and as you can probably
imagine they're just waiting to openly
market him because they're trying to
keep up the facade that he's still dead
and hasn't come back yet because nobody
knows what his role during the movie is
going to be there's been a couple
kryptonite laced rumors that'll make you
want to punch your monitor about what
they're going to do with Superman during
the film I don't totally believe them
but what I think will happen is by the
time we get to comic-con they will be
openly marketing Superman is part of all
their press materials whether or not he
winds up in a trailer remains to be seen
because I think that would give away too
much about what his role in the movie is
going to be and it all goes back into
like a big surprise that people might
not be expecting but circling back
around to Batgirl so there's that moment
of the Justice League trailer where
Gordon says to Batman it's good to see
you working with others again so clearly
he's talking about the Batman family
he's talking about the Nightwing
character he's talking about Batgirl
really anybody else that you think that
they might work into the Justice League
movies Batman's worked with a lot of
people in the past so it's a very
open-ended comment but obviously not
everybody is going to make it into the
DC EU so what will probably happen is is
it instead of sticking her in the big
Justice League team-up movies you'll see
her in the other Batman family movies
maybe not the Batman the one that Matt
Reeves is working on for Ben Affleck
because they're so far along in that in
Batgirl just recently came about and
what a crazy thought this is totally
unconcerned what wouldn't it be nuts if
the movie that they were talking to him
about not Teen Titans like I was
thinking earlier but maybe the Batman
movie before they had locked down Matt
Reeves because Joss Whedon is totally a
bigger get than Matt Reeves and talking
about the Joker just because he's such a
big Batman character a lot of you saw
this picture that Jared Leto posted and
were like hey what does this mean what's
going on so if you didn't know Jared
Leto is going to continue to be the
Joker and the DCE you they haven't
completely decided how they're going to
use them I think the less of him the
better you still use the Joker because
it's a big character but all things in
moderation so if he does appear during
the Batgirl movie hopefully it's just a
very brief flashback for Killing Joke
references like hey this is what
happened to Batgirl in the DC EU past
but as for presents
was there just so many people in
Batman's rogues gallery that you could
have her go up against did it be much
better to see new characters than to
just recycle the old ones that you've
seen in Suicide Squad and the big
Justice League movie over and over again
so let me know in the comments what do
you want them to do with Batgirl and
Nightwing inside the DCE you just
remember that they've already shot
Justice League so I'm not expecting to
see Nightwing or Batgirl actually pop up
in those movies so leave all your
requests for DC videos in the comments
below I know it's a big flash week
because it's coming back but I have a
new injustice winner to name so
congratulations to Ella you win a
pre-order a copy of injustice 2 please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for that next
video click here for brand new flash and
you can click here for brand new black
panther thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys in the
next video
you